hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar an overview of a novel rna scope
in situ hybridization technology and
applications in pathology of animal
models
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by acd a biotechnobrand
to learn more visit acdbio.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
anushka dixit application scientist at
advanced cell diagnostics and dr
sebastian monette veterinary pathologist
and the head of anatomic pathology at
the laboratory of comparative pathology
anushka and sebastian you may now begin
your presentations
thank you for the introduction
hello everyone thank you for joining us
today to learn about our spatial
platform which allows you to profile
your target rna with single cell and
tissue context
so for those of you who have not heard
about this platform the rna scope
technology is primarily an nc2
hybridization assay that was designed to
overcome the tedious
homebrew ish assays
which were very difficult to perform are
provided um
low to moderate quality results and very
non-specific signal
so we have designed this technology to
bypass all of those uh tedious
cumbersome processes and provided a
highly streamlined simple easy to work
with platform
which provides that
high signal to noise ratio and allows
you to visualize your rna biomarkers
so first and foremost why is it
important to use a spatial platform
over the last decade it's been more and
more evident that in addition to having
highly specific and sensitive
technologies it's important to visualize
your target genes or proteins with a
tissue and spatial context this is
important because it allows you to
understand where your targets are
expressing and how the cells are
oriented with respect to each other in a
complex tissue environment
understanding cellular organization is
extremely important to understand the
fundamental function of an organ or
tissue system or understand the
underlying molecular mechanism behind a
pathological condition
this is true in a lot of research areas
include cancer biology neuroscience
inflammation research
neurodegenerative disorders and
developmental biology
so when you use a platform that provides
you that spatial and tissue context it
allows you to understand
where in the tissue is your target
expressing and how is it interacting
with neighboring cells to uh provide the
function that it's meant to execute
overall in the last few years there have
been a lot of
large cell consortia that have developed
to build cell atlases for uh different
tissues and when you're doing this the
go to method is your single cell rna
sequencing because it allows you to
study gene expression at a single cell
level and profile all the different cell
types that make up an organ
but once you have this information it's
also important to understand how these
unique cells are present within the
tissue and how are they arranged with
respect to their surrounding uh cells
and that's when a spatial platform comes
into play
where now that you have that single cell
information you want to see how these
cells are oriented in the tissue and how
your targets are expressing within these
target cells
so having recognized that
rna scope technology has been around for
a decade now providing high quality
spatial analysis solutions to look at
target rna biomarkers
the key to our technology is our probe
design strategy
and in this next slide i'm going to go
over why we pride ourselves in our probe
design strategy
here
we are depicting a standard rna scope
probe as a z molecule
and
you have three different regions of the
z molecule highlighted here the target
binding site which has a sequence that's
complementary to your target sequence
then you have the pre-amplifier binding
site which forms the basis or foundation
of building the amplification tree
and then a linker region which connects
these two sequences
so as you can see we design our probes
in pairs such that when you apply your
proofs to your tissue
the probes will bind as a pair of z's
onto your target sequence
and
you will have multiple pairs of z's that
bind along your target sequence
followed by which you will have your
pre-amplifier that will bind to your
z-pair
then you will have the amplifier
which binds on to the pre amplifier
followed by which you will have your
labeled probes which can either be
chromogenic or fluorescent now this is
how we build our amplification tree on
top of the probes to give high level of
sensitivity where even the most low
expressing targets can be visualized
but how do we ensure specificity
as i mentioned for the pre-amplifier to
bind to the z-pairs
of to the z probes the two z-probes have
to bind in tandem as the
on top of the target sequence
if
the z
do the z's do not bind as a pair
next to each other
the preamplifier cannot bind to a single
z molecule as a result if a zip molecule
or a z probe non specifically binds to a
sequence the preamplifier will not be
able to bind to it and there won't be
any amplification tree formed as a
result there won't be any signal
detected and this combination ensures
very high signal to noise ratio
with very minimal background
so overall under the rna scope
technology umbrella we now have four
different aspects
we have our standard parent rna scope
assay which is for targets that are over
300 nucleotides in length
then we have our base scope assay which
is a more specialized assay that's
designed for targets between 17 uh sorry
50 to 300 nucleotides in length
we then have our micro rna scope assay
which is for targets between 17 to 50
nucleotides in length and as the name
suggests is for those small rna
molecules like srrna micrornas and asos
and finally very recently we have
crossed the barrier of the rna
biomolecules into dna and are now able
to detect genomic dna using our dna
scope assay
and the main applications for this is to
detect wireless integrations copy number
variations
and
gene fusions
so based on your research interest and
your research question you can pick any
of these assay that would best help uh
detect your target of interest
in this next slide i just wanted to show
how well adopted we are across different
research and application areas and one
of the main reasons for this is because
this technology is applicable for a
large range of sample types which
include your ffpe samples fixed in fresh
frozen tissues pbmc sculptures cells and
so forth
additionally
we are uh you're able to apply this
technology to long non-coding rnas your
standard mrnas short mrnas circular
mrnas point mutations etc
and because of that we have been
extensively used for detection of gpcrs
especially in neuroscience research
where antibodies are very unreliable for
these targets
uh to detect secreted factors soluble
factors like cytokines chemokines and
growth factors
which are secreted and if you want to
identify the cellular source of these
factors you can use this technology
one of our biggest applications which
i'll also talk about in the next few
slides is
validation of single cell sequencing
data as i alluded to in our introduction
this assay is used downstream of single
cell sequencing to visualize the novel
cells or targets identified
by single cell sequencing assays
we have been also extensively used for
detection of cdrc sequences on tcrs
which as you know is a big application
in t cell therapy research
finally with our new dna scope assay as
i mentioned we can look at gene fusions
we can study
archival ffpe
cancer
tumor samples to understand retro do
retrospective analysis about our
mutation signatures and
treatment efficacy
and finally we have been used across all
these research areas like neuroscience
developmental biology cancer research
immune oncology inflammation research
gene therapy cell therapy and infectious
disease research
for today's introduction of the
technology i'm going to show you a few
examples
of how we have been applied within few
of these research and application areas
we will start with one of our major
applications which is validation of
single cell rna sequencing data and
we're going to look at an example of how
we validated a paper that came out in
2016 which talked about um
identifying neuronal subtypes in the
mouse brain cortex
and we use this information
to
visualize these targets
visualize these targets
at single cell level
so in this slide you can see
the workflow which shows
how bulk tissue analysis can provide
single cell information when you perform
singles rna sequencing but if you want
to validate that data downstream
you have to perform orthogonal
downstream validation
and our new hyplex assay is perfectly
suited to do that wherein you will take
the information you get from single cell
sequencing and identify a few key
targets and then visualize them using
our flex assay
this particular workflow has been used
extensively to
spatially map cell atlases visualize
novel cell types uh determine the
heterogeneous uh nature of certain
targets in complex tissues
characterize immune cell landscape and
so forth
in this next example we are going to see
how we
design probes against key targets for
neuronal subtypes in this mouse cortex
and visualize them with single cell
resolution
so here as you can see we pick targets
that are specific to the d1 subtype of
the medium spiny neurons and a set of
targets specific to the d2 subtype of
the medium spiny neurons and then we
pick two targets shown here in brown
which are common for both d1 and d2 and
we wanted to visualize these in the
mouse core text
so as you saw in that quick animation
we are able to visualize each and every
one of those targets with single cell
resolution and here is a composite image
of all those targets visualized together
where you can now differentiate between
the d1 population and the d2 population
of neurons and look at the various
subtypes within these two main
populations and you can do this by uh
visualizing these target genes that are
specific to each of those sub
populations
and our registration software which
comes with our high flex assays allows
you
to look at these uh
and toggle on and off between these
targets to study those individual
populations
so in the next example we are going to
see how this technology can also be
applied to look at various immune cells
as i mentioned immune cell activation is
dependent on the type of cytokines
they're secreting and the receptors
you're expressing
with this particular assay you can
visualize both you can look at the
cytokine expression and you can look at
the receptor expression
so in this next example i'm going to
show you another workflow of our rna
scope technology wherein our ish assays
can be combined with immunofluorescence
or immunostore chemistry to visualize
rna and protein biomarkers
simultaneously
in this particular example we have used
our new rna protein co-detection kit
which allows you to optimally visualize
both your rna and protein targets here
we have assembled a combination of
antibodies and probes to look at certain
tumor tissues
in the first combination we have used
our cd68 antibody with cd163 and it can
probe liquid macrophages
and the second combination we have used
cd8 antibody with interferon gamma and
granuline b probes
so here is an example of when we used
our co-detection assay to look at target
cells within head and neck tumor and
kidney tumors
and in this zoomed in area you can
clearly see the signal in red is your
cd68
staining and the signal in green is cd
163 and signal in blue is it cam so
based on the combination of expression
of these markers um you can identify
whether potentially or m1 or m2
macrophage here you can see nice
co-localization of
cd68 with cd163
potentially suggesting it might be am2
macrophage similarly in this kidney
tumor you can see very strong expression
of cd163 in this particular cell
um so
these are the type of analyses you can
perform using the score detection assay
where you use a immune cell specific
antibody marker
and you use target gene
rna scope probes to identify subtypes of
immune cells
in this next example we have applied the
same assay to look at uh cytotoxic t
lymphocytes where you're now looking at
a cd8 positive cells in red and you're
looking at expression of soluble factors
like interferon gamma and granazine b
are suggesting the activated state of
these t cells
so here the cell marked in the purple
arrow indicates a triple positive cell
which is a potentially active t cell in
this tumor
so this is really great where you can
identify specific subtypes but a lot of
the times uh researchers are really
interested in visualizing multiple
subtypes simultaneously on the same
section of the tissue
and so we heard what researchers wanted
from us and we developed this new
version of the high flex assay which can
now be used in ffpe tissue and we are
calling it the hyplex version 2 assay
which can be used in fresh frozen fixed
frozen
and ffpe tissues alike
so what we have done with this new
version of the assay is pretty much kept
the workflow the same
but we have introduced a sfpe reagent to
ensure that there is minimal to no
autofluorescence from the sfpe tissues
because ffbe tissues are known for high
autofluorescence and the last thing we
want is the real signal getting masked
by autofluorescence so our research
scientists have really worked hard and
optimized this assay to work on ffpe
tissues where you can now visualize 12
targets simultaneously
and here is an example in ovarian cancer
tumor where we have selected key immune
oncology targets like your immune cell
markers key cytokines chemokines
your hypoxia markers
to be visualized in this tumor micro
environment and as you can see you can
actually visualize where there's high
degree of t cell infiltration versus
where there's high levels of macrophages
present in this tumor and furthermore
with our registration software you can
pick which targets you want to visualize
at a time and in this particular image i
have only selected my key t cell
specific targets which include cd3 cells
cd8 positive cells interferon and pd1
so these are your key t cell markers
and now i can specifically say where
exactly are the t cells present and
which one of these are your cd8 positive
cytotoxic t cells
so this is how you can toggle between
your target genes and identify exactly
where your immune cell population of
interest is present in this tumor micro
environment so this is just one example
you can really play around with this and
identify
your um cell type of interest and study
their organization within any complex
tissues
an interesting
feature of this assay again is that
although we have been able to plex it up
to 12 in ffpe we have not lost the
sensitivity and specificity of the assay
well again we can go down to that single
cell single molecule resolution and
really hone in on those specific subtype
of immune cells and identify
where these cells are present in your
target tumor
so finally i want to touch upon
an application
which is
pre-clinical safety and
activity assessment of car t cells now
this is a very important application as
more and more car t research is
happening to develop uh party therapies
and solid tumors
we've seen some success in um
uh leukemia and lymphoma but we want to
see if car t cells can really be
effective in solid tumors and to address
that we we collaborated a couple of
years back with blooper bio in cambridge
where they were developing certain car t
therapies and wanted to use our
technology to assess the safety and
efficacy of these treatments
so here is a
depiction of how we um assisted them in
achieving that goal we developed a car
specific rna scope probe which would
specifically detect the car vector of
these car t cell therapies
and ultimately we treated these
treated mice with these car t-cell
therapies i wanted to see how these car
t cells react in a pre-clinical model so
there were two car t-cells that it
developed one against the bcme antigen
and the other against the roar of
anantation
so first we'll see
how uh this treatment worked against the
bcmu antigen so in this image on your
left hand side you see um a
staining done on the xenograph tumor of
this mouse
where we have
we have used a probe against granozyne b
and approve against the car utr and as
you can see you can detect the car t
cells marked in red and also see that
granos ion b expression is very high
which indicates these cartier cells are
active and mounting a strong immune
response and that's only because the
bcma antigen is present in the xenograft
tumor
we also use a multiplex assay and
combined it with immunofluorescence to
differentiate endogenous car t cell
endogenous t cells marked in white from
car t cells marked in green so you can
use any of these assays to really help
address the question you're interested
in here we were able to show that the
carcase has a present an active
secreting granazine b and interferon
gamma
on the other hand or the raw one therapy
did not work as well where we saw that
it had some non-specific effects which
was causing pulmonary toxicity in these
mice so overall the study was very
successful it showed uh that the
raw one our treatment was not as
effective but the bcma treatment was
effective and
showed very strong response in this
preclinical model so this is the last
example and hopefully today i've been
able to show you that this technology is
highly specific uh and sensitive in
detecting targets of your interest
we have over 35 000 probes in our
catalog against a wide range of targets
we can flex up to 12 for ffpe and up to
48 for fixed and fresh frozen tissues
and we can detect small rna targets as
well
finally we have tweaked our technology
to be compatible with our
immunofluorescence and ifc assays so you
can visualize protein and rna targets
simultaneously
and with that i will now turn the
platform back to our moderator
for our next talk
thank you anushka for the
great introduction to the technology
this is sebastian and thank you mary for
the
introduction earlier and the opportunity
to speak
um
i'm going to move on to
my presentation
so
as mary mentioned i am a veterinary
pathologist
at a core facility called the laboratory
of comparative pathology
so we are a multi-institutional core
facility in new york city so we are
affiliated with memorials from kettering
cancer center the hospital for special
surgery the rockefeller university and
the wild cornell medical college
so before i talk about how we've been
using this technology in our core lab i
just wanted to give a brief overview of
our workflow and what we do just so you
can get a better idea of how this
technology fits within our activities so
really the um the core of our services
uh is our team of four pathologists um
so we are for board certified
literary neuropathologists specialized
in animal models and we support a large
number of users
at our institution by doing a slight
interpretation for a wide variety of
pre-clinical studies
but we also in our lab have
the facilities and the staff
to assist people with the entire
workflow so this starts with
most in most cases submission of the
entire animals to our lab so we do
perform the necropsy tissue harvest and
fixation slide preparation so we really
do this so that we can assist people
with these um steps and also we can
perform this in a standardized manner
that is optimal for our pathology
assessment
then the slides go to our pathologist
for slight interpretation and pathology
reporting and also in a subset of
studies uh we will
perform
some form of image analysis in addition
to the pathology assessment we will
perform some form of image analysis with
software to characterize
various features within the
sections and this is typically done by
scanning the slides generating whole
site images
so being pathologists we um
the bulk of what we do is really
interpreting histopathology sections
making diagnoses so
our routine
slide that we use in most cases are hne
slide sections however
we do
incorporate in many of our studies
some form of detection of markers or
targets of interest in tissue sections
and by markers or targets i mean
either
protein that we can detect by using
antibodies for immunostore chemistry or
immunofluorescence or rna by
using rna probe with insitu
hybridization using the orange scope
assays
just
some common examples of when and how or
why we need to
detect targets within tissue sections
our most common
needs are
include
some examples that anushka already
showed so for example characterizing
immune cell infiltrates in the tumor
microenvironment that's something we do
very commonly we also do a lot of car t
cell studies and in some of those we
need to do exactly what anus anushka
showed which is to assess the target
distribution of the car t cell so we can
better
understand and assess
things like
uh of tumor on target toxicity
um so then there's really the question
when we start planning these experiments
are we going to detect the protein with
ihc or the rna with ish
and um in some cases clearly based on
the scientific question um one or the
other is more appropriate so sometimes
you know there's no choice really it's
because of
some reason specific to this study we're
only interested in the protein or only
in the rna but in many cases um
we're we consider both options equally
they're both
potentially appropriate we know that uh
in many cases if the protein is
expressed it's there we also expect to
see the rna so then we really have a
choice and what i want to talk about
today is um how do we make this choice
what are the advantages of fish over ihd
for
our people for our pathologists and our
user ihc is still for them often the
default it's still often the first thing
they ask for um i think one of the main
reasons is they're more familiar with it
we've been doing ihc in our lab for
decades
um rna-ish is newer we started doing it
with rnscope a few years ago
also with ic often we already have the
antibody or people have an antibody
they're familiar with
so um it's often the first choice but
what i want to show you today is that
clearly there are some cases where there
are very marked advantages and uh we
will want to use ish instead of ihc
um for us they're both there are both
performed in a very similar manner this
uh image shows the automated standard
that we use in our lab the leica bond rx
platform um it works both for ihc and
rna scope edge
the same technicians that were already
trained and experienced with ihc
they're able to very easily run the
issue it's
it's run in a very similar manner
and also on the same type of formula and
fixed paraffin fitted tissue sections
to illustrate this um i wanted to use
this example so this is a study uh in
which um
we use a um in which a
syngenic b16 melanoma mouse model was
used and this is uh from one of the labs
here at msk so i want to thank our user
and collaborator jill wang from the
world chat club for letting me use this
example
in this study he had two groups of mice
with b16 melanoma implanted in the flank
um the two groups where there was a
control group there was a group that was
treated with something that i'm not
going to discuss today but basically
they were comparing the two groups um
using various characteristics of these
tumors and and one of those aspects in
these studies was assessing some targets
so we did use rna probes for ish
staining for these three targets that
i'm showing here cxcl 10 il-10 and tgf
beta
the first thing that you can appreciate
and what one aspect of this that we
really like as pathologists is that we
can see not only
if the target is expressed and how how
intensely or how much of the target is
expressed but we can also see our tissue
morphology in the tissue sections
so we can see our histopathologic
features i can see that not only the
target is expressed but i can see for
example in cxcl10 that the red signal
for the rna target is within the tumor
cell within mostly the cytoplasm of the
tumor cells the pattern is very
different in il-10 i don't have signal
in the tumor cells however i do have
intense signal in a small number of
smaller cells that appear to be in
between the tumor cells these most
likely are some type of immune cell that
we could characterize exactly which type
they are with further staining
and then finally in tgf beta you can see
some very small numbers of fine dots in
the tumor cell so there is a small
amount of rna within the
tumor cells of this melanoma but the
most intense staining is within the
blood vessels
it appears to be
mostly in the endothelial cells of the
blood vessels so already i can see
qualitatively that
there's very different source of the rna
between these three markers within the
same tumor
but this is not unique to ish um this is
iht so in the same project on the same
tumors we did ihd for some immune cell
markers uh including cd3 cd8 and fox p3
for various populations of lymphocytes
and f480 for macrophages
um i also get my tissue morphology in
ihd
so
then the question is
why did i choose to do ihd in these
cases than ish for the other markers
for these immune cell marker these are
stains that are very commonly requested
in our lab so we have um
antibodies that we keep in stock we have
well optimized stains we feel that these
in most cases work well for us so that's
why
in this case we use ihc but why did we
use
why did we use the ish for the other
tree markers so these three markers were
in the case of il-10 and cxcl10 we had
never stained for them this was the
first time we had this request
in the case of tgf beta we had done in
the past imminent chemistry using a few
different antibodies
the results were never that great so we
really wanted to achieve something
better
so really having
a request for novel markers we know that
um if we need to start to find
antibodies it's not always easy to find
good antibodies and to optimize them so
and often the the
available antibodies are limited so for
some of these markers sometimes we
search
commercial vendors and sometimes there
are no antibodies available that are
already validated for immunostore
chemistry almost on formula six paraffin
embedded tissue sections for the target
and species of interest or sometimes we
do find a few antibodies but
when we start trying them we find that
they work somewhat but they're really
not that great and this brings me to the
next point is that a lot of the um
relatively poor sensitivity and
specificity that we experience with many
antibodies um this is really not an
issue with the ish that's something that
we really like about the ish staining is
that the sensitivity is very high
as well as the the sensitivity and
specificity both are really high and um
i'll show you an example later where i
have side by side um ish and ihc and and
i can show the um how how the ish is
performing much better and is more
sensitive
we also tend to save a lot of time with
ish when we are faced with novel targets
like these
um so as you probably know when we get
new antibodies for ihc even though they
often come with a recommended protocol
we really always have to optimize them
on our in our hands on our instrument to
get the best possible staining and we
have in our lab
hundreds of different antibodies uh for
which we have protocols for ihd and they
each have a slightly different protocol
so different
different epitope retrieval different
primary antibody concentration and so on
so we need to keep track of that and and
optimize each antibody accordingly
that's really not the case for the
rna-ish
for the rna scope assay we have one
protocol that's been always the same for
all the targets we've used and it's
always worked very well so typically
when we get we receive the probe we just
put it in the machine we run it with the
standard protocol and on the first day
we can start generating data um that's
quite different from the antibodies
where often we spend a few weeks to
optimize you know try a few different
antibodies optimize this pain so we save
a lot of time
and then finally um
we find that the uh ish tends to be more
suitable for quantitative assessment of
target expression and what do i mean by
that so
going back to the immune cell markers
which we assessed by
immunohistochemistry
um
in this case we're really only
interested to know if a cell is positive
or negative so we're going to use image
analysis
to quantify or to
to
classify these cells
either as simply positive or negative
and then we're going to quantify how
many positive cells
are present per area of tumor tissue
so it's simply a positive versus
negative cell for this we find that
these markers work very well
uh with ihc however
in the case of these three markers the
il-10 tgf beta and cxcl10 the scientific
question was not simply
positive versus negative it was really
about
the
degree or the amount of expression her
cell within these
samples
and for that
the
ish is very well suited because the
staining pattern is this
punctate staining so you see these
little dots and you can actually
count either
manually or you can also do this with a
software for image analysis you can
quantify how many dots are present in
each cell and it's been shown uh in some
of the validation data of these assays
that the number of dots per cell that
you see on the stain correlates with the
copy number per cell
um
so that's quite quantitative um ihc
is not going to be uh shown as dots it's
really you're going to see staining that
is either hydroplasmic or nuclear or
membrane um
you can try to
quantify the intensity or what we would
call the optical density of the
chromogen with ihc
but as many of you probably know that is
really
often not recommended because it is well
known that the optical density or the
intensity of chromogen with ihd is
really not
correlated in a quantitative manner to
the amount of targets so at best with
ihc you would get a very rough
semi-quantitative assessment of how much
protein is there and we find that the
ish is more quantitative
um
so this is what i was just describing we
do have um
these are the softwares we use uh qpat
which is open source and halo is a
commercial software both of them have a
very good
algorithm
for um ish where the dots within the
cells will be detected and then the
cells
can be or the number of dots per cell
can be quantified and you can generate
once you set this up if once you have
if you have a good stain you have good
imaging then uh you set up your image
analysis and then you can rapidly
generate in an automated manner
a large amount of quantitative data
the other um
advantage uh that i wanted to talk about
briefly for the rna-ish is the the fact
that we can really rapidly translate
from sequencing data to morphologic
analysis
so the study i showed in the study i
showed these three particular targets
were identified as
targets of interest
from a single cell rna sequencing data
so concurrently as we were doing
histology in these tumors there were
also some samples from the same study
that were going for single cell rna-seq
analysis
this generated a large amount of data
and after it was analyzed it was found
that um it appeared that
uh these three targets were of
particular interest
so then uh the uh the user asked us if
we could spain um often in my experience
the type of targets that are now
identified on single cell rna-seq um
are not the type of targets that we can
aimly find antibodies for so these are
some examples again so we're
able to rapidly go from the single cell
rna-seq to the staining of our tissue
section to validate this data and
analyze it further with the
spatial aspect
but
this rapid translation
of the sequencing data to tissue section
staining is also true in my experience
and that's something i wanted to show is
also true and is very powerful if you're
involved in um this is very different
type of study but in novel pathogen
discovery
so i want to talk briefly about
this example um
being a core facility we we mostly um
support
research done by other groups however we
do have our own small research program
being lab animal veterinarians and
veterinary pathologists were interested
in
spontaneous diseases of lab animals
including mice
and there is this disease called
inclusion body nephropathy that had been
observed for
about the past 40 years by veterinary
pathologists
so it's a spontaneous disease of mice in
which
the
kidneys undergo a chronic kidney disease
that's characterized by tubular
degeneration and necrosis as we can see
here on the right
the kidneys eventually undergo
interstitial fibrosis they start to
shrink and be misshapen
at that stage often the mice will show
evidence of clinical disease they will
become sick because of renal failure
they will have very high creatinine in
their serum
and what's very interesting is that the
tubules that are affected have these
enlarged nuclei with intranuclear
inclusion bodies shown by the arrows
which if you're familiar with
pathology of infectious diseases these
type of inclusion bodies are highly
suggestive of a virus as the cause of
the disease
we have been looking for a long time as
a potential viral cause for this disease
and and we could not find it with
traditional method
and that was until um a few years ago
with collaborators we did um viral
metagenomic analysis of
these
kidneys from these mice with chronic
renal failure so basically she did
high-triple sequencing of these kidney
tissues and went we went hunting for any
evidence of a normal viral sequence and
we did find it so we did find with our
collaborators a sequence that was
present in multiple of these kidneys the
same sequence that was compatible with a
parabol virus but it was a it was
compatible with the new or novel parvo
virus species which we named mouse
kidney parvo virus
however
we needed to show not only that this
virus sequence was present within the
tissue affected by the disease but we
needed to prove causality
and this was done by uh multiple
different experiments to show that this
virus was indeed causing the inclusion
body nephropathy but one of the key
experiments we did was with using rna
scope so very rapidly after we got the
sequence we sent it to order a custom
probe
in a couple of weeks we had received our
probe and then we applied it to the
tissue section and we were able to show
these really beautiful images that
showed how the viral rna was present
in the tissue it was present in disease
tissue it was not present in kidney
tissues of normal healthy mice and also
spatially it correlated so you can see
that the signal is present in these
abnormal tubules with enlarged nuclei
and showing attenuation of the
epithelium that's consistent with
tubular degeneration and not present in
the normal tubule so for pathologists
that's very powerful evidence if you
have colocalization of the infectious
agent with the
lesion that's really support causality
we could have done this with immunostore
chemistry but it would have taken
probably a few months to develop an
antibody and actually we eventually did
that so a few months later we did have
in addition to our ish
the
immunostochemistry assay it did show a
similar pattern of staining
but the fact that the ish allowed this
allowed us to do this so rapidly after
the sequencing data was obtained um
really helped us to you know to get this
published fairly rapidly and have very
convincing data we also found that even
though the iht worked very well in the
kidney tissue
it was not as sensitive so then
after characterizing the disease and the
kidneys we wanted to know even though
there were there was no evidence of
pathology in any other organs we wanted
to stain all other organs to see where
else this virus may replicate in the
mouth and we did find it by ish
in
a small number of cells and you see that
the intensity of staining is is much
less than the kidneys but you see these
small dots within a few cells within the
small intestine mucosa and the sequel
mucosa
and we found that this occurs actually
very within a few days after we
inoculate mice with this virus that's
the first place where we see it before
it goes to the kidneys so that's been
very useful for us to study the
pathogenesis of this infection um but
the staining is is very is much milder
in the intestine and actually when we
applied our antibody to the intestine
even though in all the mice we could see
the staining on ish we never never were
able to visualize it with antibody and
we think that probably is because the
amount of virus in the intestines is
much much lower than in the kidney and
the
we're just below the sensitivity
threshold of the immunos to chemistry
assay
this is another
similar story another novel mouse virus
that we found in our facility it's
called urine astrovirus2 it was
discovered by viral metagenomics
and
we
rapidly after obtaining the sequence we
ordered the probe we're able to confirm
that this virus was infecting our mice
we were able to study the
pathogenesis of this virus and and
follow it in different tissues after
experimental inoculation
but i also wanted to show this example
because
in this
study
we combined the rna probe for the
astrovirus rna
with antibodies for different cell types
so this is the small intestine on the
left is the
astrovirus probe in red and cd3 in green
showing that one of the main cell type
that was infected in the small intestine
were t cells with cd3 but there was also
occasional colloquialization with
epithelial cells labeled with
pancytokeratin
antibody
so um
this was my
last slide this this concludes my
presentations
presentation
again
thank you
anushka for sharing this opportunity
with me today
i also want to thank everyone for being
here and
i'll be happy to answer any questions
thank you anushka and sebastian for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is for anushka
does rna scope detect insertion and
deletion of mutations
anushka
and we seem to be having some connection
issues let me ask a question for uh
sebastian
do the probes cross react for the same
target in different animal species
um
so i think this is also
possibly something anushka may want to
comment on since she's the expert on the
technology but i can give you my um
perspective as a as a user of this
technology so
uh
that's often a question we had when we
ordered probe and i think the answer is
it depends how
um
how
closely similar or different are
the same gene in different species um so
when we order the probe we've asked this
question before so for example and
that's important to us because we often
work for example with with humanized
mice where we want to detect only the
human gene and not the same gene of the
mouse so we've asked this question
before and then um they can run
the uh there is a probe design team at
acd they can run
uh an analysis within their um
with using their algorithms and they can
tell us whether or not it would cross
react in some cases they will say it
would definitely not cross-react in some
cases they say it will and the advice
they gave us when the genes if the gene
is too close between the two species
the advice to us was to use instead of
the rna scope assay was to use the base
scope ac because it can be more specific
to
shorter sequences
hey
um let's try a question for anushka
does rna scope detect insertion and
deletion of mutations
can you hear me now yes
great
yeah i just want to thank um dr monette
for his time today and for that
brilliant presentation and for this
question
um our dna is capacity which is our new
assay specifically designed to look at
genomic dna that is the assay that
would help visualize these insertions
and deletions
so not our rna scope assay but our new
dna is capacity thank you
all right
um next question this is for you anishka
does this technology work for archival
ffpe samples with poor rna quality
a great question um i think sebastian
showed a few nice examples of archival
fspe samples and a short answer is yes
absolutely
the way the probes are designed they
span across a range of
length of your target rna and they are
basically a pooled probe
of
about 20 zz pairs for rna scope and
about one to three zzz pairs so they are
a set of probes and that ensures that
even for fragmented rna you will see
some level of signal
so
um archival ffp tissues with poor iron
equality
can be used with this technology
okay thank you
our next question is for sebastian
how do you choose between chromogenic
and fluorescent assays
yeah so that's a that's a good question
um and
i think
so
as pathologists here in our lab we tend
to like the chromogenic assays because
they really give us
a really good view of our tissue
morphology so you know we can look side
by side at the h e and the chromogenic
slide
also our pathologist can examine the
chromogenic slides you know on their
regular microscope at their desk so it's
just easier to look at them routinely
however
to us the
reason to choose the fluorescence assay
is really when we're trying to do some
sort of colocalization staining um
there is a it is possible and we have
done a dual staining with chromogenic
assay it works fine if there's not
overlap between the two signal but i
would say and and i think the same is
true also i'm sure people will be
familiar with this and
many people will probably agree like if
you're using antibodies uh if there's
going to be colocalization in the same
cell within the same cell compartment
let's say cytoplasmic target within the
same cell um two chromogenic
um chrom two chromogens overlapping is
very difficult or impossible to assess
so then colocalization of multiple
marker multiplex staining um in my
experience is when you want to go with
the fluorescence
right thank you
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
uh this one i think is for anushka is
the new rna protein co-detection kit
available for automated assays
uh thanks for that question um
yes our co-detection
assay is available in both automated and
manual platforms so depending on
whichever one you prefer and whether you
have the instrument you can use either
all right well thank you again anushka
and sebastian for your time today and
your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor acd for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye